lo que tenemos aquí es una economía con
una brecha de producción como puedes ver
la producción de equilibrio a corto
plazo se encuentra por debajo de la
producción con pleno empleo a esto se le
conoce como brecha de producción
recesiva en otros vídeos hemos hablado
sobre los mecanismos de corrección a
largo plazo que existen cuando nos
encontramos por debajo del pleno empleo
por ejemplo cuando la gente sobre todo
la que quiere conseguir empleo dice oye
estoy dispuesta a trabajar por un
salario más bajo entonces nuestra curva
de oferta agregada a corto plazo se
desplazaría hacia abajo y tenemos una
situación como esta en este caso esta
será la gp2 nuestra curva de oferta
agregada a corto plazo 2 y así tendremos
un equilibrio a largo plazo donde la
producción de equilibrio es igual a la
producción con pleno empleo pero
supongamos que esto no ocurre supongamos
que vivimos en un mundo donde por alguna
razón no existe un mecanismo de
corrección y nos quedamos atascados en
esta brecha de producción recesiva
tenemos que eres el gobierno y quieres
hacer algo al respecto para volver a la
producción con pleno empleo
bueno pues existen dos herramientas para
conseguirlo por un lado tenemos la
política fiscal vamos a escribir la
política fiscal que se relaciona con el
cambio en las cantidades que gasta el
gobierno vamos a escribirlo esto será el
gasto gubernamental
y con el cambio las cantidades de
impuestos
una teoría dice que si el gobierno gasta
más la producción total se incrementará
otra dice que si el gobierno cobra menos
impuestos habrá más circulación de
dinero en la economía y eso también
podrá incrementar la producción total
también está la política monetaria no
vamos a hablar detalladamente sobre ella
en este vídeo pero la política monetaria
tiene que ver con la oferta monetaria si
hay más dinero en circulación las tasas
de interés disminuyen y con eso
podríamos aumentar la producción aunque
también podría ocurrir lo contrario
vamos a escribirlo aquí tenemos la
oferta monetaria y las tasas de interés
pero esto es asunto de un banco central
nosotros vamos a concentrarnos en la
política fiscal lo que el gobierno
quiere que ocurra es que esta curva de
demanda agregada se desplace hacia la
derecha y llegue a un punto como este
entonces el gobierno quiere que la curva
de demanda agregada se desplace hacia la
derecha como aquí
esta base de a 2 la demanda agregada
pero como lo conseguimos cómo hacemos
que esta curva se desplace hacia la
derecha para que llegue hasta este punto
en el que tenemos nuestra producción con
pleno empleo bueno pues como ya dijimos
existen dos herramientas que podemos
utilizar el gasto gubernamental y los
impuestos ahora bien es un error común
pensar que incrementar el gasto
gubernamental en 100 mil millones de
dólares equivale a reducir los impuestos
en esa misma cantidad porque asia habrá
100 mil millones de dólares más en
circulación dentro de la economía para
incrementar la producción tenemos que
ser muy cuidadosos y no olvidar lo que
aprendimos sobre los multiplicadores
todos estos son modelos muy simples pero
debemos recordar que un multiplicador
habitual vamos a escribirlo aquí un
multiplicador habitual es 1 sobre 1 - la
propensión marginal al consumo mientras
que nuestro multiplicador fiscal vamos a
escribirlo va a ser igual si tenemos un
incremento en los impuestos al negativo
de la propensión marginal al consumo
sobre uno menos la propensión marginal
al consumo ponemos el signo negativo
porque un incremento en los impuestos va
a tener un efecto total negativo sobre
el gasto y la razón por la que tenemos
esta propensión marginal al consumo en
el numerador es que si mis impuestos se
reducen en supongamos 100 dólares en
función de mi propensión marginal al
consumo si ésta es menor que 1 lo cual
siempre debe ser así no voy a gastar los
100 dólares sólo voy a gastar una parte
de ellos en realidad es la propensión
marginal al consumo por 100 dólares
mientras que si el gobierno gasta 100
dólares sencillamente van a ser 100
dólares gastados
para ver el impacto o la diferencia en
el impacto dejemos esto así por un
momento y hagamos un ejemplo supongamos
que nuestro gobierno gasta 100 mil
millones de dólares vamos a escribirlo
el gobierno gasta 100 mil millones de
dólares cuál va a ser el impacto
imaginemos que estamos en un mundo donde
la propensión marginal al consumo es
igual a 0.8 cuál va a ser el efecto
sobre la economía en este caso bueno
pues vamos a multiplicar los 100 mil
millones de dólares de gasto
gubernamental por el multiplicador 1
sobre 1 - la propensión marginal al
consumo que es 0.8 esto va a ser igual a
100 mil millones de dólares entre 0.2 y
0.2 es un quinto así que esto va a ser
lo mismo que dividir entre un quinto o
multiplicar por 5 entonces tomando como
base este sencillo modelo vamos a tener
un incremento en la producción de 500
mil millones de dólares
aquí en nuestro multiplicador fue 5 pero
supongamos que en cambio el gobierno
decide
y los impuestos en 100.000 millones de
dólares vamos a escribirlo disminuye
impuestos en 100 mil millones de dólares
y supongamos que tenemos exactamente la
misma propensión marginal al consumo
entonces en esta situación cuál es
nuestro multiplicador fiscal estamos
disminuyendo los impuestos así que esto
va a compensar este signo negativo
entonces el incremento en la economía va
a ser nuestros 100 mil millones de
dólares por la propensión marginal al
consumo que es 0.8 dividido entre 1
menos la propensión marginal al consumo
bien esta parte de aquí es exactamente
lo mismo que tenemos acá así que esto va
a ser igual a 500 mil millones de
dólares
esta parte por 0.8 esto va a ser igual a
400.000 millones de dólares una vez más
piensa de manera intuitiva de dónde
salió esta cantidad bueno si el gobierno
gasta esos 100 mil millones de dólares
son 100 mil millones de dólares gastados
y de acuerdo con la propensión marginal
al consumo la gente que los obtenga va a
gastar 80 mil millones de eso y luego la
gente que obtenga esos 80 mil millones
va a gastar 64 mil millones y así hasta
que finalmente terminen siendo 500 mil
millones pero en el caso de la
disminución de impuestos no
necesariamente vamos a gastar esos
primeros 100 mil millones supongamos que
yo pago todos los impuestos de este
ejemplo si me los reducen en 100.000
millones puedo ahorrar una parte tomando
como base esta propensión marginal al
consumo voy a ahorrar 20 mil millones y
a gastar los otros 80 mil millones es
por eso que de acuerdo con este modelo
simplificado aquí podemos obtener un
impacto total menor
este es un aporte importante la política
fiscal va a cambiar el gasto
gubernamental o los impuestos pero de
acuerdo con estos modelos utilizará un
multiplicador diferente por lo que no
necesariamente van a ser equivalentes
hasta el siguiente vídeo